Washington Post which used to be just
kind of a liberal newspaper and now is
just pure propaganda and unreadable
estupid
managed to somehow blame the president
for hurricane Florence they said he was
quote complicit in the storm because of
his positions on climate change it's
pretty big claim to make is it true we
thought we talked to an actual
meteorologist on the question not just
in New York Times Washington Post
propagandist dr. Roy Spencer is a
meteorologist he's the principal
research scientist the universe of
Alabama in Huntsville and he's the
author of inevitable disasters why
hurricanes cannot be blamed on global
warming doctor thank you very much for
coming on tonight well thanks for her I
know that you acknowledge the earth is
getting warmer and there's debate about
why but there's also this second debate
that plays out in the popular press
about whether the warming trend is
causing more severe weather events like
hurricanes is it well it has gotten
warmer as you said since the 1950s there
has been a warming trend but what we
haven't seen in terms of any long-term
weather measurements is whether there's
been any change in severe weather there
hasn't been any increase in hurricanes
that's on a global basis in the United
States the frequency of hits of the
United States by major hurricanes has
gone down by 50% since the 1930s and
1940s
there's been no increase in droughts no
increase in floods tornadoes are down
but still weather varies a lot
especially hurricanes year to year
decade to decade so there's a huge
amount of variability okay
some of them stall produce a bunch of
rain certainly North Carolina is going
to have a major flooding disaster but
this is what Mother Nature does
naturally and if there's a human
influence in there you wouldn't know it
because there's so much natural
variability so I'm confused a week I
know that we keep pretty good records on
hurricanes going back more than a
hundred years so the data are available
to anybody with Google we know whether
or not there's been a dramatic increase
and you just stated the numbers for us
so given that there hasn't been how can
people claim there has
spen and that global warming is to blame
I don't know why do people like the
Washington Post say such stupid things
it's because the people that are
informing us in the media about global
warming are people like Al Gore Bill Nye
the Science Guy neil degrasse tyson
people that don't know anything about
atmospheric science you just have to
look what i'm sorry let me let me just
interrupt you Bill Nye is a science guy
it's in his title so that that doesn't
mean he knows a lot about atmospheric
science well no he doesn't he's not a
trained scientist I believe he's an
engineer of some sort plus he has a
widely viewed YouTube video called
climate 101 where he faked an experiment
he put co2 into a jar and shone a bright
light on it and tried to show that it
caused the jar to warm up inside because
of the extra co2 but a TV meteorologists
Anthony Watts cleverly showed that the
whole thing was faked
it's it's ridiculous I you know and I
believed in Bill Nye the Science Guy
till tonight doctor thank you it's nice
to have someone who actually knows what
he's talking about on the show I
appreciate Thank You Tucker